[MUSIC]
So I want you to think back on
if you've received an email
from a political campaign that read
something like this or this or this.
So this is what my inbox looked like,
last week and I'll come clean.
Having worked on a campaign,
I've sent 1000s of these emails.
A belated apology if any of you watching
are from the state of New Hampshire.
Now, it may come as a surprise,
to hear that emails are a major part
of how candidates reach voters.
However, I'm sure it's no surprise to
hear that they're incredibly ineffective.
Click through rates are abysmal.
And studies have shown that excess
outreach actually reduces intent to vote,
it's counterproductive.
However, on a campaign,
there's no time to experiment.
No time to consider new strategies.
We do what's been done before.
In fact, over the last two decades,
the playbook for
driving voter turn out has
not significantly changed.
We've just gone from donor thing
to bar worthy vision spam.
And yet working on campaigns, are baffled.
Given the billions spent on
elections every four years.
How do we not have a better system for
voter outreach?
Or even more broadly,
why does it seem that the issues
plaguing our democracy are unended?
The lack of secure voting, disinformation,
partisan districting, I could go on.
So this is what I'm here
to talk about today.
1, what's wrong with our democracy, 2,
why democracy entrepreneurship
might be the solution and
3, how we can fund and support this work?
So let's start with the first question.
What's wrong with our democracy?
Most Americans once acknowledged
a few universal truths.
The sun will rise,
Tom Brady will enter the Super Bowl.
And American democracy will persist.
Now fast forward to 2022.
Tom Brady's retired and
according to a recent poll,
64% of Americans I believe that
US democracy is in crisis.
Now, this is a harrowing fact.
Our democracy is the system by which
we peacefully transition power and
hold leaders accountable.
It is because of the resiliency of
our democracy, that we have free and
fair markets and why the US dollar
is the world's reserve currency.
Without a trusted government,
we cannot fight corruption,
advocate for human rights or
pursue justice.
These are the promises that
a healthy democracy delivers.
Thus, it is baffling to think that we
are not only ignoring improvement,
but we're actively moving backwards.
The last time trust levels in
the American democratic process
were this low was in the 1850s
in the lead up to the civil war.
The nonpartisan electoral
integrity project ranks
the United States second to last
among liberal democracies and
57 overall, in administering trusted and
fair elections.
We must completely reject
the notion that our democracy will
magically bumble into better times.
It won't without active intervention.
So, with a laundry list of issues in tow,
you'd guess a country like
the United States, so
focused on relentless improvement,
would throw its full weight
into revitalizing democracy.
However government isn't civilized
to tackle democracy reform.
And I can think of a few reasons why.
1, it's hard to use the system
to change the system.
Politicians aren't civilized to open
the process that puts them in power.
2, dependency corruption,
the constant need to fundraise for
elections often drives
partisanship over progress.
3, polarization, and
trench polarization makes any
chance a passing by partisan
electoral reform difficult
And 4, the scale of government,
even donors who are passionate
about democracy, think they can
just support perform candidates.
However, reform from the politicians
cannot unilaterally make progress.
So because government isn't
incentivized to tackle this issue,
we need to do what America does best,
turn to our entrepreneurs.
In this case,
I'm talking about democracy entrepreneurs.
Democracy entrepreneurs represent a legion
of passionate and patriotic leaders.
They include technologists,
they include research organizations,
they include community organizers and
they include advocacy
groups that drive innovation and
change in a space that needs it.
It is because of democracy entrepreneurs,
at ballot ready that we have access to
state and local level ballot
information with two clicks.
It's because of democracy entrepreneurs
at Rock the Vote that we can register to
vote online.
It's because of democracy
entrepreneurs at Politifact that we
have near instant fact
checking of politicians.
Whereas private sector entrepreneurs
innovate in antiquated industries and
social entrepreneurs take on
issues tackling societal safety.
Democracy entrepreneurs
are working on solutions to build
a government of the people,
by the people and for the people.
Their key distinction is that they're
not chasing a financial exit.
They're often nonprofits or
social welfare organizations.
So we've laid out
the issues of democracy and
identified who is best
position to fix them.
So now to address the last question,
how we can fund and support this work?
To best illustrate this, I'll share
a story about a time that I worked for
a democracy entrepreneur at Vote Rev.
we used behavioral science and
organizing expertise to drive
bipartisan voter turnout.
It was September of 2020 and
our organization was unstoppable.
We'd raised over $10 million.
We'd recently doubled our headcount.
And we were actively turning
out thousands of early voters.
Now fast forward to February 2021,
exactly one month after the run offs.
We were no longer
receiving contributions and
over 50% of my colleagues
had been laid off.
The core issue is that
infusions of political dollars
are painfully tied to elections.
Every 4 years, candidates and political
groups are flooded with billions.
And like clockwork post elections,
those dollars dry up.
No matter how successful we were in 2020,
we couldn't raise our series B.
We had to downsize just like hundreds
of other democracy ventures.
And just like that,
progress was ground to a halt.
And our democracy remained stuck,
waiting for the inevitable,
another election, for
those funds to come flooding back in.
So, this is the fate of democracy
entrepreneurship today.
Blessed and dammed by the whims of donors,
tied to the shoe strings of
political contributions and
wholly dependent on
the cyclicality of our elections.
So how do we fix this.
The first part of the solution involves
reallocating political dollars to fund
democracy entrepreneurs.
Every 4 years donors give over $10 billion
to campaigns and political groups.
And only a fraction of a percent of
that money goes towards strengthening
democracy.
Just like we do with science and
infrastructure,
we need to make more
investments in democracy and
we need to make them more
strategically and longer term.
The second part of the solution
involves supporting this work.
This is where you all come in as
future investors and operators,
we need to empower this work by building
accelerators and incubators by cementing
democracy innovation, as a part of
corporate social responsibility.
By providing technical
resources to founders and
by evangelizing to build the movement.
I am calling for
a pro mass democracy mobilization event.
It's about time we recognize the service
of democracy entrepreneurs and
flood them with funding and support.
We do this with the goal of inviting all
Americans to co-create our nation by
giving them a fair say in
the forces that govern their lives.
And I'll end with this,
it's not about which side wins,
what matters most is for
American democracy to win.
[MUSIC]